any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
it is a great pleasure to welcome
a gentleman who's been a great influence
on me and my writing but we've never met
in person we still have never met we
have to meet someday in person paul
but it's uh it's uh professor paul
halpern who's a professor of physics
at the university of the sciences in
philadelphia he's the author of
16 popular science books all of them are
fascinating
and some of them are undoubtedly known
to everyone out there in the audience
such as the quantum labyrinth which is
fascinating and einstein's dice and
schrodinger's cat he lives in
philadelphia pennsylvania first question
i have for you paul you've done so much
you've written so much you're an online
you're an intellectual
you're a scientist you're a professor
how do you think of yourself what is the
core uh
element of who you are as a human being
on earth
well first of all i wanted to thank you
for inviting me on the show brian
and in terms of my own self-conception i
guess i always
think of myself as being a person of
ideas i love to discuss
ideas with people and um i also
really love nature and i have
a mixed reaction to technology as as do
i think many people
but i love technology but i also love
being away from technology i like
kind of communing with nature walking in
the woods
um bicycling and so forth so that's
about as
that's as much a part of me as
doing highly technological things like
that that's
actually i didn't expect that why is
that why do you why is that so
uh intrinsic to who you are are
important to you
i feel like nobody should um
should have one way of defining them and
i and and i'm somebody who's always
liked to have
different aspects of my personality and
i i recall
for example when i was back in graduate
school doing my phd program
i really narrowed my horizon doing a
thesis
very mathematical thesis on general
relativity and cosmology
and then i started to feel really down
and really
isolated and i felt almost zomified just
working on this mathematical project and
then i said to myself well what's going
on
and what was going on is i didn't have
other aspects of my life
so once i got away i had a bicycle at
the time
i'd bike into wooded areas or bike along
the shore of long island where i was or
right poetry wasn't which wasn't
particularly good but
it still brought me out of my mind and i
just felt much more balanced
so i vowed from that point forward never
to be unbalanced
always have many different activities
and that's a sort of a key in some of
the personalities in this book and i
think this book is a departure
and correct me if i'm wrong from your
previous books it spoke loudest to me
and i couldn't put it down i listened to
the audiobook
i read the physical book as a companion
but you know i kind of feel like you're
in my head and that was important and
and appropriate because i felt this is
almost a book about
not only human psychology but also about
friendship
and the first thing i want to talk about
whenever i see these books and i know
you know when it has quantum in the
title you know i talked to my friend
david kaiser who i'm sure you know
i've talked to many other physicists you
know written
interpretations of quantum mechanics
actually i told david kaiser i said
my first fear when i was reading quantum
legacies which is his book that came out
this past year
was that it was not going to be another
quantum uh interpretations book
and and i looked up i said i wonder if
that's an acronym n-a-q-i-b
not another quantum interpretations book
it turns out
it is an acronym or it's a word in
arabic and it means
a person of great understanding so
in a way you are not quib but uh but
this book isn't really about that it's
really a book
about personalities and friendship can
you uh can you talk to me what was the
most surprising
relationship that you uncovered in the
research and writing on this book
well it was interesting to see all the
different aspects of wolfgang paulie's
personality
because he could both be a hard-headed
physicist
and quite mean to people but then he
also had this very sensitive side
it shows that no matter how hard-edged
somebody is
and no matter how gruff they might still
have this
very sensitive uh side and and
be you know be vulnerable in some ways
and he was very vulnerable
about his relationships uh he
you know his first marriage was a
disaster and he had
a lot of trouble relating to women and
that's when he turned to carl jung and
uh and that became a kind of a
friendship and unlikely friendship
between the two of them it was more of a
professional relationship rather than i
would say
you know they weren't really pals but
they got very close intellectually and
had a very interesting dialogue between
quantum physics and
psychoanalysis
[Music]
and that of course is the main thrust
behind the title of course synchronicity
i always like
to tell my uh guests that unlike the
advice to never judge a book by
its cover i always judge a book by its
cover and not only that but also
the title and the subtitle so can you
take us through the title what you know
how did you come
up with it uh it's the shortest of all
your titles i think
uh in some ways uh but uh but also the
subtitle the epic quest to understand
the quantum nature
of cause and effect so it's not about
interpretations what was the design what
are the design elements that went into
it
and what's the meaning of the title and
the subtitle for my audience
well first of all i think it's a
beautiful cover in terms of the
the design layout although i can't take
credit for that i didn't
suggest the design myself but the
designer at
basic books hachette did a great job
with that
in terms of the title i was trying to
encapsulate this whole idea
of a causal connections through time and
this whole mystery
that if you look back on ancient times
the ancient greeks were debating whether
or not light
whether or not light takes time to
travel from the sun to earth
or whether light is instantaneous and
that meant a big deal because
light was symbolic in ancient greece of
things like love
and divine influence there was a whole
theological idea
about light that if you were you know if
light touched you you were being blessed
and
you were given wisdom through light and
um there's there's ideas in mysticism
uh you're probably familiar with
kabbalah where uh
where light come comes down through
vessels and that's
a symbolism of of god's influence
on both the universe and on human beings
let there be light yeah
right first sentence so light plays so
much of a raw
if light is instant then divine
influence
and any kind of causal influence can be
instant
so you say something and all of a sudden
thunder or lightning can strike
and that's it but if light takes time as
we know
then certain things must take time and
and if you wanted if you were angry for
some reason
with the people on alpha centauri you
couldn't immediately
i am i really hated it
five minutes later the people on a
planet near alpha century okay
we're going to we're going to affect
your weather five minutes
we're going to send you some kardashians
you know i'd have to wait four years for
light to light to travel there
because that's how long uh causality
takes and yet
there seem to be in quantum physics now
things
that are not necessarily sending
messages but are influences
uh in terms of of a common core
such as quantum entanglement that happen
instantaneously or near instantaneously
as far as we can tell
and that means that you can have
things are connected a very long
distance in space
but not necessarily need um the time for
light to travel from one end to the
other
for them to share information and that's
very interesting to me
so back to the title well if if i wanted
to make a really long title i would say
well
the history of a causal influences
throughout time
and then i just thought well jung even
though i
i thought jung was not completely
scientific in terms of his ideas about
you know day-to-day coincidences i
thought well it was really insightful of
him to come up with that term
to describe an a causal connecting
principle and science needs an a causal
connecting principle
a way to understand a causality as well
as causality
so why not use that term and trace the
idea of a causality back to the ancients
and trace it forward in time and use the
relationship between pali and young as
kind of
the the keystone of the book upon it
what everything
which everything else is built and then
go backward in time go forward in time
so that was my aim i think if i were
writing this book
and you know that's the highest in
comium that i could give i wish i wrote
this book right
um but you know if i were writing it i
would worry that you know
i get caught up in a little bit of the
you know dancing woo lee masters dust
and the
the dao of physics and so forth because
synchro you know young is not
as you say associated with the highest
levels of
of scientific rigor and you know
preparing falsification
etc and yet he influenced you know one
of the most important physicist
who's really poorly understood of our
time how did you avoid
you know kind of the pitfalls of getting
into the woo-woo
aspects of oh everything's entangled in
our hearts and so forth
and it's a very rigorous but it's it's
it's full of wit
and it's such a charming book it's an
emotional book in some sense
i was very moved by their relationship
and even aspects of betrayal
and you treat them you know i'm sorry
for such a meandering question but
but in in other books and maybe to an
extent you know i thought you pulled it
off very well with wheeler and feynman
in the quantum labyrinth but you know
there's a tendency to lionize physicists
like feynman and and even you know
wheeler certainly einstein
right is otherworldly but this is a very
human portrayal
and i guess how how did you navigate
between the shoals of of kind of
you know portraying them with all their
flaws but also
really stoking the curiosity of the
reader to want to learn more about the
topics
that these two men were so deeply
invested in
well i guess over time i've been writing
for
now uh 30 years believe it or not so
it's it's the 30th anniversary this
october of the publication of my first
book
oh congratulations yeah time journeys
yeah i want to get into that
which is really strange because i
started writing when i was in my 20s
yep and uh you know you can do the math
in front of
how old i am now yeah you know what
idiot unfortunately
10 years older than me that's all
but anyway um i know that
a segment of my audience is going to be
people who are very seriously interested
in history of science
there's a segment who's in who are
interested in just the science itself
and then there are people who are kind
of like wow i want to learn about higher
dimensions
i read maybe they read something but
that is
pseudo-scientific but they're more
they're interested in learning more
about the science behind it so i feel
like part of my job
is to attract people who are
interested in science but also kind of
interested
in i guess souther some of the what
would be called new age
topics and to tell them okay well this
is where science
stops and you can have your faith you
can have your feelings but
this is a scientific method and if you
want to learn science this is what
science says
and that's what i i do during my talks
um
i you know if someone asks me a question
i'm very respectful
if they say well what is you know what
does science say about
the afterlife or what does science say
about you know this matter of faith
i i respectful of people for their faith
but then i say okay that's
faith that's religion that's not what
i'm talking about i'm talking about
scientific experiments so that's what i
try to do to delineate it so
um you know that was one of my goals in
the writing
and the you know personalize it so that
people are interested in the
personalities
are satisfied i try to put in some
scientific explanations
and uh of course no matter what i do
there's always going to be someone who
says
too much history or too much explanation
it's
you know and they're i never know what
the background will be
to someone picking out my book like
sometimes there are people
who pick up a book like for example my
feynman wheeler book
they read everything that feynman ever
wrote maybe read everything that wheeler
ever wrote
and they're kind of like oh yeah been
there done that i know all these stories
like halpern's not putting in anything
new and then there's people who pick up
the book
like richard feynman i wonder what he's
you know so who he is i guess he's a
scientist and then like
pick you know start reading it and have
no idea who richard feynman is
but then learn something though i can't
exactly
have like different versions of my book
like this is for the person who
knows everything about fine this is for
the person who knows nothing about
then it'll appeal to nobody yeah so i
try to make it
on a level where a lot of people can
appreciate it i try to hit try to hit
the middle ground
so that someone who's interested perhaps
in a little bit of
about modern quantum entanglement
experiments
will learn something uh whereas if
somebody is really
just interested in the history they can
skip that section or skim that section
and look more at the ancient history
yeah there are all sorts of books you
know that have been written about
you know not only the individuals uh but
then there's the you know kind of
struggles within the individuals adam
becker's book
uh what is real and you know i always
come away
with uh with a feeling of a little bit
of
of being you know still still hungry
after reading it because um you really
can't
come up with a definitive explanation
otherwise we would have you know
we'd understand all the loophole
closings and we'd understand
you know what alternative is correct and
interpretation is correct many worlds
ever ready and you know
etc but but at least and this isn't the
criticism at all it's just
at least we come away at a minimum you
will come away from reading
synchronicity
with an appreciation of of the
characters
a very a very intimate you know kind of
portrayal of the relationship and
most of all the stakes involved are so
high
between these characters and and as i
say love
you know unseemly character behavior
even betrayal notoriety
and credit uh but getting back to the
notion of time the gears on the cover i
i don't know if that was intentional but
you know the words become sort of like
interlocking gears and a clock
it really you know made me think a
little bit about when i was doing
research for my book
uh about the nobel prize that i i was
wondering what was the first prize ever
you know come up with and why do people
you know care about prizes so much and
it turns out at least one of the first
prizes i could find out was really the
longitude prize you know trying to
understand
where the earth where on the earth's
lines of longitude a sailing ship was
located
and that was very important and very
deeply related in fact in you know
inextricably related to measuring time
which is very difficult to do on a
pitching deck of a boat
and i didn't include much of it if any
of it in my book but really that
longitude prize
was attempted to be won by none other
than galileo
himself and he had this complicated
contraption of like a
helmet with a telescope in it to look at
jupiter's moons and
and a lot of it was done to win this
prize and and you know a monetary prize
a prestige prize
which then later after centuries morphed
into
uh the nobel prizes having some elements
of inventions and discoveries
but at its most basic core um this is a
conversation i think humans have always
had
um not only on like how you measure time
and if two events are
contemporaneous but what is the nature
of time
and you know it's not often i get to
talk to an intellect like yourself
how do you think about time i mean what
is time
to you if you have to explain it not
not to your grandmother or whatever but
how do you
paul halperin how do you think about
what time is
intrinsically because i think unless you
can explain that
you know notions of synchronicity are
interesting but
but you're missing kind of the forest
for the trees so to speak to use a bad
analogy
well time is such a mystery for all of
us and and
we're always fighting against time and
grappling with time and
run out of time um it's it's very
strange
to me and this is going back to my first
book time journeys 30 years ago
um it's strange to me that there's so
many ways of geometrizing time
like looking at time as a circle looking
at it as as a straight line
and then by roll and then
uh there are ideas about um
psychological time there's physiological
time
relativistic time so time is obviously
something that can be
sped up or slowed down in different ways
um there's
you know of course relativistic um time
dilation
but then you know the fact is if you're
if you're waiting
uh for an hour let's say in disney world
you're waiting in an hour to go on a
ride
and uh that might seem like to take
forever
and then you go on the ride and it
flashes by like that you know
because you're having so much fun and
and it's just strange how the brain
works it just
there seems to be a connection between
events
how we're experiencing events and uh
the more events we're noting the faster
team
time seems to go by so if we're we're
not really
you know if if we're kind of um
you know in them immersed in something
time really seems to whiz by but then if
if we
our minds can't really hold on to
anything and we're kind of like thinking
about things and and things aren't
happening then time
slows down so i've always been
fascinated by this this difference and
why
um why for example when you're
when you're on vacation um time might
seem to whiz by
but then looking back on it if you look
back on a vacation
you might be able to remember every
single day because
you know it's very eventful but then you
look back on like two weeks
in the middle of a semester and you're
kind of like oh
i don't think anything happened then
yeah tell me about i've got
a bunch of kids at home and it's like
the months fly by
even the weeks fly by the years fly by
but the days drag on and on
it's like when is it 7 30 these guys got
to get in bed so i can have some
alone time with my wife but i remember
for example my first
trip to europe which was a six week trip
and i remember almost every single day
of the trip and it kind of expands
in my mind but you know a comparable
six week period in in early 2020 i
remember all the details time doesn't
exist anymore during the code
but yeah i mean is it a politically
incorrect you know
attribution to einstein of you know time
is relative you know
sitting on a stove for a second feels
like an eternity
and talking to a pretty girl for an hour
feels like a second
or whatever but it was young interested
in in the perception psychological
perceptions of time or was he
noted in this more interested in the
spooky action at a distance aspects of
synchronicity
well i think he felt he felt that they
were connected he felt
like he wanted to link psychological
perceptions to
physical ideas now he wasn't really
the person to do that because he didn't
he never really had a
a serious background in physics but he
was very interested in talking to
physicists and bouncing ideas of a
physicist
going all the way back to his connection
with einstein so in the early 1910s
when einstein was teaching at the
university of zurich and the eth in
zurich
um briefly jung had dinner with einstein
several times
and that's when jung start to think
about space time
and space time has many attributes but
in general relativity
you can think about the possibility of
signals being sent backward
in space-time theoretically because you
can think of space and time as a block
this block universe idea and and
einstein didn't really
talk about it too much but jung was
really fascinated with the idea
that maybe um space-time
the fact that it's a hall means that
causality
is an illusion and that we can really
contact the past we can contact the
future
and con and that two people can share
an unconscious identity they can share
ideas you know even though they're
separate people
and i think jung was fascinated with
this and that's why
jung was amazed when paulie wrote to him
a quantum physicist and shared all these
dreams with him
a lot of the dreams had some connections
with with quantum physics or at least
with symmetry
and it was just this treasure trove for
jung of ideas and that's
when jung further developed the idea of
synchronicity
which he had come up with before he met
jung but then
really fully developed while uh sorry
before he met paulie
but really fully developed after he met
paulie and then they bounced ideas off
of each other
i'm sure it was uh you know incredibly
um gratifying for young to have this you
know
eminent physicist you know creator of uh
exclusion principle
idea creator of the neutrino idea uh to
have such an imminent personality
you know taking his work seriously
engaging with him
um maybe uh you know maybe it was
it was fortunate that they did meet at
that time but i guess they
the question that you know i was
thinking about maybe this connects to
your first book
um time time journeys a search for
cosmic destiny and meaning
um what is it about about time
that seems inextricably connected to
meaning
we talk about this and there's a
personal connection in my book uh sorry
my um reading of the book in your book
uh
with a character who you mentioned dr
andy friedman who unfortunately passed
away this summer
uh and uh participated actually the
founder of this quantum bell experiment
that you
describe in the book but um you know and
kind of
feeling like oh we're always we'll
always be entangled and we have this
entanglement and a lot of the eulogies
for andy
involve that very metaphor what about
you know physics is relative or related
to or relevant to
to meaning i mean a lot of people would
say there's nothing that you know
other than it causes me a lot of trouble
to pass my you know my my freshman
physics class
how does how does physics or cut or
astronomy or whatever
how can that impact the meaning of life
well there's this whole teleological
idea
in physics and also in theology and
even though people try to keep them
separate a lot of people think about the
far
future and they think well where is this
all heading
and if the universe for example
it ends in a cycle and
you know there were some ideas in in
philosophy in particular nietzsche's
idea
that we might someday repeat everything
and i don't think many physicists take
that seriously
but imagine if if we ended in a cycle
and everything started all over again
and that somehow our atoms
ended up you through true
chance maybe after a number of cycles in
the same position and we we lived our
lives again and again
in this kind of eternal return then that
would have a profound difference
compared to
whether or not um we live only one life
and i think um part of our motivation
toward
having goals and towards having meaning
in our life
having a perspective is this idea that
time is fleeting
and we don't really have a second chance
and that we're trying to do
everything we can in this life trying to
go for everything in uh i know it's kind
of a cliched expression but in a bucket
list
like checking off things that we need to
do in our life because
we know we're not going to have another
chance whereas if those who believe
let's say in reincarnation or in cosmic
cycles
i think well i need to lead a just life
but the fact that i travel here or
travel there really doesn't make a
difference because
i'm going to have another cycle i'm
going to have another opportunity
it's more like well i have to build
toward the next cycle
so i think if you believe that
our atoms will come together again
versus believing that
everything is fleeting and will end up
in like a state of maximum entropy
there's kind of a different perspective
on uh on
the meaning of life yeah it's funny that
you bring that up because i was talking
a couple days ago with uh rabbi david
walpe who's one of the more famous
rabbis in
in america today he's a thinker and
author and i actually asked him about
that i asked him if
if a bucket list is a jewish concept you
know in other words
is that something that comports with
judaism and his answer is essentially
no uh although there are provisos that
you know you
are commanded essentially to observe in
judaism to
to to not observe but to partake of all
the permissible pleasures
you know you're not you're not permitted
to partake of a blt
but you are permitted and you should
command yourself in a sense to take
a voyage to the alps you know these are
beautiful you know
the majestic wonders of the world and
and really in the sense to cultivate and
inculcate a sense of gratitude
um and i wonder well as you were talking
i was like
do you have a bucket list paul i don't
really
think about that okay i i think about
i think about the immediate future um
i love traveling so i guess the closest
for me would be uh countries or
parts of the world that i've never been
to um
like speaking of rabbis i've never been
to israel but i'd always
i've always wanted to go there oh yes
so everybody else in my family has been
there so it's kind of like
i'm the one left out um but i'd also
like to travel to
you know um to africa south africa is
supposed to be beautiful
um you know parts of asia that i haven't
been to so many parts of the world
i have traveled a lot so traveling is
one of my passions
and interests and uh i've been to india
once but there are
parts of the himalayas and parts of
india that i've really would love to go
to
so i guess that's the closest closest
that i have to a bucket list is
is seeing the rest of the world yeah
so uh an allied question that i asked
the rabbi
uh the other day about that is what if
time for you
wouldn't be finite in other words what
if you took what my
seven-year-old is working on assiduously
uh the never dying pill
if if if he can get it through clinical
trials uh would you take it would you
want to live forever and you
are the only one living forever no no
causes where you get to save it
so you wouldn't uh that's that's a
interesting question but i guess the
caveat is
is being the only one living forever
yeah
i i always think of that in terms of i
mean this is this is a little bit
hokey or far-fetched but there's there's
an aspect of the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
where everybody has their own timeline
and in everybody's timeline perhaps
at every junction one's mind takes the
timeline in which one survives
so if if there's some some kind of event
and this this i should tell you those
who take quantum mechanics seriously
this is a little bit far-fetched and
hypothetical but imagine if
every time there's a quantum measurement
the human mind
uh takes the version or branches into
the version
for survival and that part dies off and
part
survives like let's say i mean to think
of a far-fetched example imagine
if um you're near a radioactive material
and you're either blasted with radiation
or not blasted with radiation
well part of you would survive because
one branch of reality would be the one
in which you're not blasted with
radiation
so you would survive that so imagine if
you kept surviving in your mind
everything that happened and then all of
a sudden you realize hey wait a minute
i'm thousands of years old what's going
on but everybody else
i ever met has died because they were in
a different timeline
right so i mean that could happen
um so if a thousand years from now
you're in your own timeline and i'm in
my timeline
and you think well i'm the only one left
in the world and i think i'm the only
one left in the world will realize
that this idea of of quantum branching
is
is true after all yeah that's an
expensive experiment which actually
brings up my next topic which is
you know we we're at the point now where
colleagues such as my
late great colleague andy friedman and
anton zeilinger jason galiccio
david kaiser and others have been
looking
at ways to close different loopholes and
bells inequalities
um i kind of feel like we're at peak you
know
peak bells inequality or so like where
we've really closed so many of the
loopholes
yeah there are a couple more left and
you go through them and the most
readable account to date
um sorry to david kaiser no he his book
is is is less about that than some of
the other attributes of the
age of the nucle of the nucleus and the
age of the bit
um but uh but in reality you describe
this in a very accessible fashion
but i almost feel i always felt like
andy was always talking about well the
next step is to go from
uh these quasars at redshift two you
know which is like
uh you know three quarters of the way
back to the big bang basically
so and he wanted to use patches of the
cmb which i specialize in
and and do quantum um and close certain
loopholes but i'm like
it's kind of diminishing returns even if
you you know
it becomes a a question of you know how
when do we stop these experiments and
and just
and just agree you know that these
violations are all taking place
are we are we at this diminishing
returns point in your opinion or no
yeah i always wondered about that
because the first some of the first
entanglement experiments involved like
crossing or teleportation experiments to
crossing the danube river
right that sounded really exciting wow
you can send information across the
danube river
but now it's like okay you can send it
to a satellite you can send
information to you know exchange
information about quasars and so forth
um it almost seems like people are
trying to outdo each other
but um i mean i can understand why
people do this
and it's kind of you know let's
establish
once and for all that bell's inequality
works and you know that quantum
entanglement is real
but i agree with you that at some point
you kind of have to say
well we have to accept that there are no
hidden variables yeah
because i i don't think anyone really
well i shouldn't say
i think there's a small subset of
physicists
who believe in hidden variables but i
think the majority
believe in uh you know about
ben bell's inequality applies and that
um
that quantum entanglement's real and
that maybe there are some physical ways
of
dealing with it but they would have to
fall within fall within
you know satisfying bell's inequality
and speaking about experiments
uh once more it's interesting to me to
think back
you know we kind of hold carl popper's
demarcation
uh you know philosophy up as the
apotheosis
of what is science and what is not
scientific
leaving aside that question specifically
historically he was driven to kind of
formulate that as a response
to freudian psychoanalysis and
and i wonder you know reading the book i
mean
if paulie who obviously was you know
such a
such a titan of scientific method you
know if
how he could maintain the cognitive
dissonance
that it must have taken to know that
like some of these things couldn't be
falsified or
or proven in a sense do you think that
he just said well this is
this is the you know a topic for a
future time or
was he willing to suspend it because of
a form of confirmation bias
how do you square that circle between
this eminent scientist
overlooking you know one of the one of
the hallmarks that the text
the test the test cases for popper
which is psychoanalysis being
non-scientific
dream analysis especially
[Music]
i think paulie was very careful this was
kind of a private venture
so he had this private life he had
almost
uh or close to a breakdown around 1930
which is
which is interesting because he proposed
the neutrino that year so he had
these scientific breakthroughs but then
almost a nervous breakdown around the
same time his marriage yeah
because of his marriage his mother
committed suicide a few years earlier
had his failed marriage his wife ran off
with a chemist
he said like a bullfighter i can
understand
but a chemist what would you run up for
the chemist
so because of that this was a very
personal thing
he kept kept it very private these were
his
conversations with jung and then he had
a friend uh pasquale jordan
um who was a german physicist who took
ryan's uh psychic experiments much more
seriously
and paulie at first kind of dismissed
these
and i think he always was always kind of
like well let's see how this pans out
let me see i'll talk he he talked to
young
he talked about symbolism he was
interested in these ideas
but uh he never published
ex you know with one exception he never
published anything about these ideas and
the one exception was
his work about uh kepler's astrology and
symbolism in kepler's astrology
and he meant that as a kind of
historical analysis based on jung
interpretation but paulie would not
go to a journal like a psychology
journal and say
hey wait a minute like telepathy is real
he was not like that he kept it very
private he
people didn't know that he was a patient
of jung until
they co-authored this book one was
one uh chapter was synchronicity and the
other was
uh paulie's uh analysis of kepler and
then
people said hey wait a minute they're
collaborators paulie is a young secret
patient
and then they realize that so now it's
an open secret that
that um paulie is a young secret patient
but
paulie really didn't want a lot of
people to know that yeah
and i think you know to give him the
benefit of the doubt it might not
only have been because he was
embarrassed or
perhaps skeptical of the ultimate truth
of what young was proposing
but also because there's this kind of
halo bias the fact that
oh well this great man nobel prize
winner you know uh
et cetera he's doing this and so now i'm
gonna confer
unearned uh you know allure and
and a prestige to a field maybe he
didn't know it would actually pan
out so yeah i think that's admirable i
didn't look at it as he was you know in
the closet because he was
you know scared of being exposed but
maybe as you know it's like
they cut out einstein's brain right and
then what
not that much different i mean you
probably know more than i do about it
but uh
but um i want to just you know kind of
uh start
winding up by talking about what makes
quantum mechanics so perplexing
and you know why there are so many books
why did you think
this book you know had a had a need to
be written which i which i
agree with it did why why at this time
are there so many books written about
you know quantum mechanics different
interpretations entanglement reality etc
what what is the cause of that according
to you well i just wanted to add
about um the last point that i found in
my research
in the archives at the eth i found a
letter
i'm not sure how well-known this is
there's a letter
from ryan to jung saying that he
received a letter from paulie
posthumously
that probably had doubts about ryan's
work yeah you mentioned that in the
and the acknowledgments right mm-hmm
yeah yeah i was i was going to ask you
about that
well paulie was halley had become in his
final years his final two years
more skeptical i think and he also
didn't correspond with jung as much and
i i have hypothesized
that maybe it was the fact that in 1957
um parity symmetry breaking was
discovered
in the weak interaction and paulie was a
big believer in symmetry
and then he thought hey wait a minute
maybe symmetry isn't everything
there's a symmetry breaking and he
started to doubt a lot of
his preconceptions and around the same
time i don't know if it's coincidence or
not
that's when he he stopped uh
corresponding with jung for a while
and that's when he wrote the letter to
ryan expressing his doubts
but back to your other question about
what why it's interesting about
quantum measurement and so forth well
the interesting thing is
in the 19th century before quantum
theory
you could very easily distinguish
between psychic stuff
spooky stuff and real physics
and the way it can distinguish is you
say okay is everything happening locally
if the answer is yes it's physics okay
everything in newtonian physics happens
locally
and then you say is everything happening
deterministically
if the answer is yes it's physics if
it's random chance
then you say well maybe we don't really
understand what's going on we need to
look at all the components maybe the
randomness comes from a lot of
components
but if someone said okay this happened
just completely randomly
no explanation you might say well that's
not real physics
if something happens here and then a
mile away something else happens
and there's nothing in between to
explain what's going on
say well that's not real physics so it
was very easy
to demarcate science from non-science in
the 19th century
and then quantum mechanics comes along
in the 1920s and all of a sudden people
are talking about this
black box idea we don't know what's
going on inside
you take a measurement you get a result
you can have take a measurement
one place you get a result another place
and then it's kind of like okay what's
science versus pseudoscience
and that's why i think einstein kept
talking about spooky
it's too spooky it's too much like
pseudoscience we need to go back to real
science and einstein really thought
that quantum mechanics had adopted the
language of telepathy
of pseudoscience and that needed to
quantify itself more and that's why
einstein kept trying for a unified
theory of nature
that would supersede quantum mechanics
and be completely local
and completely deterministic
that explains explains a lot of the
fascination because you know you have
these great quotes from these great
minds and
fineman's quit that nobody understands
it and
einstein's quote about spooky action at
a distance
i wonder you know sometimes when you
talk about this i'll be talking with
um uh juan mao the sena
in a couple weeks about an interesting
paper that you
reference a precursor to in this book
about uh traversable wormholes
uh and of course you know many worlds
and the multiverse things that i'm
involved with sean carroll's written
about
um it seems to me that um
and not with your book as an exception
and i tried to be
a little bit of an exception in my book
but um it seems to be like kind of a
little bit of overselling taking place
in the works of you know michio kaku or
even brian greene or or folks like that
who i
great respect for but that we really
have to make
physics like extraordinarily bizarre
and and almost you know paradoxical or
else
the public won't be interested in it and
um i wonder your take on that
there's also proliferation of that like
oh there's a wormhole over here
there's you know teleportation what do
you make of that
yeah well i have to confess my second
book was about wormholes i know i know
and i was i started the trend again you
started the trick
i look back on it and i say well okay
wormholes are like subways but then i'm
kind of like
well you know maybe it was a little bit
a little i did say well
perhaps for civilization millions of
years from now and i
said well you would need you know the
amount of energy or matter
of a galaxy to construct one right i
think i think i had all these
caveats and escape clauses but still you
know
i think the fact is that um if you're
going to trade books
if okay if you're not doing a scholarly
book
people are saying well what's the angle
why is this going to attract people
so i think there there often needs to be
a balance
because um you know if i wrote a book
about um bianchi type
9 cosmologies and chaotic elements which
is
you know that's a must-read that's a
beach read like okay
i'm taking that to the beach i mean
that's my
my phd thesis but you know
if i said like you know uh if i phrased
it like
you know chaos in the cosmos or
something like that it would be
more like lasalle but then when people
find out just about an obscure universe
model
they might not be so interested in it so
i try i try to have a broad appeal
at the same time i'm hoping that every
statement in the book
is scientifically valid i i i try to
take care to say okay
this is hypothetical this is speculative
this is real science um so when i
for ex in some of my books i talk about
you know everett's
hugh everett's work but i say well this
is not accepted by everybody and some
people think
it it's very far-fetched to imagine you
know millions of copies
of reality and so forth sean carroll's
favorite uh
favorite scenario for yeah yeah
so i try to be i try to be strike a
balance and
and it's not going to be for everybody
as i said there might be people
who want to talk about more far-fetched
things and that's not me
but then there are people who are kind
of like well unless
unless you're talking about the standard
model that's been verified for
you know decades you know it's too
far-fetched to describe to the general
public
i can understand that yeah i just try to
strike a balance
and you do it exceptionally well so i
want to conclude uh
the conversation with questions that i
ask all my guests and i'm
i'm sort of expecting not to put too
much pressure on you but you know
your answers will be really illuminating
and illustrative and maybe tap into a
love of
sci-fi i know that you've uh you have a
love of the simpsons and you've written
uh about a book about the simpsons and
you've appeared in their 20th
anniversary 3d special you have an imdb
page it's pretty enviable but i want to
ask you um
some some questions uh about your
future and even your past and so it's
appropriate for a book about time and
synchronization so the first things
about the deep future
it's a question i've asked many people
that have been guests on the show
and that's this concept of a will but
not a material well
an ethical will instead of material will
and
the notion of what you leave
behind is more important the material
things decay
uh and and fade away people spend your
money whatever
but um but what you can leave ethically
in terms of the wisdom that you've
accumulated
is what i'm curious about today so if
you were going to leave a an ethical
gift for humanity what would it be what
kind of wisdom would you
include and not not technology we'll get
to that in a second but
what ethical or piece of wisdom would
you most like to
um to bequeath to humanity
well i think two aspects of my life that
i would share
are first of all i'm a great believer in
having
a balanced life and having
goals that are personal goals that are
not necessarily public goals
and right now there's there's been this
big movement to try to make put
everything
into social media and people describe
all their activities and you know
everything about somebody
i think people should be in some ways a
bit of a mystery they should have
aspects of themselves that are personal
not everything should be public
so i really believe in having that kind
of balance
and i also believe in trying to put
yourself
one self in other people's shoes and
i one of my favorite songs the song by
phil oakes
there but for fortune go you or i and
it's been covered by joan baez and other
people and
it's a song about the fact that
people in prison people who are starving
refugees
they all could be us and i think people
don't
take enough time to think about what it
would be like
to be born in a country where there's
famine
there's war and what what those people
must be like and then you think
well should we take in more refugees and
people sometimes view that question
selfishly like oh my gosh
how would that affect our country but
then you think what would it be like
to be homeless and to have no
opportunities
and to try to raise children for example
knowing that the children
might end up poor and not have a job and
then
have this idea of going to another
country
well i think about the perspective of
refugees
and i would like my children and so
forth to put themselves
in other people's shoes and i'm happy to
say i have two
sons that are that very much feel like
that and and are always thinking about
other people's perspectives
yeah i'm really happy about that i've
said before
with previous guests that you know i
view children and it's not just
biological children it could be adopted
children it could be
ideological children are graduate
students
as the only form of time travel
teleportation that exists because you
get to teleport
not only your dna i think that's
relatively meaningless
in the grand scheme but your values
and if you can do that you can achieve a
form of immortality yeah you might not
be there but
a part of you will be and that type of
you know entanglement
is anything but spooky because i think
it's it's something that's
uh that's unique to the human condition
that we have that ability
to transmit our values and teleport them
into the future and i think that's
beautiful what you just expressed
uh the next thing i want to do is
express also into the future but
something materially
that you've come across in your in your
immense uh
career as a scholar as a guggenheim
fellow and all the things that you've
done in your life
um inspirational to to authors such as
myself
but what piece of knowledge or
technology
would you put in an obelisk of the kind
that
sir arthur c clarke depicted in 2001
these machines used by an unseen
civilization
to uh store information about
uh that would only be openable you know
once
humanity was able to go to the moon and
actually unlock the secrets within what
kinds of
things would you put on or in
a billion-year-long lasting time capsule
well thinking about that question i
think well what does a human race really
need
what what sort of you know technology
does it need
and i wish there was a way i don't know
if this is true technology or through
education
that we could abolish war particularly
um weapons of mass destruction and that
is of course a big fear
i share that fear with a lot of people
but this idea that the human race
could wipe itself out the fact that
wars go on constantly and then the fact
that that even
on a local level there's so much
violence and so forth
and i would i would really like to see
humanity
evolve and sort of the star trekking way
into global
civilization or intergalactic
civilization if possible
i mean talking about the far far future
that believes
in peace and respect respecting other
cultures
respecting other alien civilizations if
they exist
and just being emissaries for for
understanding i know that sounds kind of
hokey maybe it's
not at all actually it's impressive oh
fashion but
i would really like to see the end of
warfare the end of weapons of mass
destruction
no you're in complete agreement with
none other than jim simons dr jim simons
the world's smartest billionaire
actually i don't know maybe you're a
billionaire you could be the world's
smartest billionaire for all i know at
the university of the sciences they
they probably pay better than here but
but anyway i'm not complaining
uh jim simon said you know the most
important science is political science
because if we don't figure out a way to
cooperate we're going to obliterate
ourselves and that's the highest
priority that he had as well so you're
in
you're in good company paul okay great
last question
is uh before we get to the spin zone the
plug zone at the very end
uh the last question is now we're gonna
go backwards in time uh
assuming that such a thing is even
possible but um
sir arthur c clarke had one of his three
laws the first one being any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
the second one being for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
and the third one was the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's of course
where i get the name for the podcast
so i want to ask you what thing about
life
might have seemed impossible to you uh
as a
as a 20 year old as a 30 year old maybe
someone said it was impossible
and you found out you did it because you
went
and had the courage to go a little bit
into the impossible
well i think as a 20 year old i i was
very
confined locally i grew up in
philadelphia so i'm the
unique unusual academic should say
that's ended up in the same
town where i grew up and i traveled a
little bit around
uh the united states um east coast
united states
but hadn't traveled too much and hadn't
really met
you know that many well-known people and
i guess
um i kind of imagined or
you know i felt very nervous about um
you know traveling and and meeting
people from different cultures and and
meeting well-known people
and i kind of i guess i was very i'm it
was very humble
i was from sort of you know a a
quasi-suburban part of philadelphia and
i didn't feel like
i had the aspirations to be like
somebody who could
talk to well-known physicists and so
forth
so i think i think i i was very
[Music]
careful very early on in my career
not to reach out
to to well-known people and so forth
and maybe you know my early books and so
forth
they would have benefited by me saying
i'll just pick up the phone and call
nobel prize
winners and i'm sure they would have
answered me you know answering my
questions so i could have written to
them
but then finally um around
a little after 2000 on 2002
i got a guggenheim fellowship
for the history of higher dimensions i
thought well
i have this guggenheim fellowship thing
maybe i can try to contact people who
are well-known
and that's when i reached out to john
wheeler and had an interview with him
and it just felt great to be talking to
him and he was such a well-known person
and i could ask him anything i wanted
and i just thought well this is
you know this is something that i could
pursue so
since that time i felt i still feel a
little nervous approaching people
but i feel like i can reach out to
people who are
nobel prize winners or famous and talk
to them
and i'm a lot less timid about that
that's really good it's good to know uh
although it's a little depressing
because maybe he could have had 17 books
i think i saw your hands moving i think
you're working on 18 and 17 as we speak
you know you're
actually writing a book during this
interview it's amazing
uh speaking of what you're going to be
up to now and i want to say paul in all
honesty
the way you describe talking to you know
people like wheeler etc
i i feel like that talking to you your
wealth of knowledge
um your your your mensch as we would say
and
and you do so much for um communicating
science to the public but you do it
in a way that doesn't dumb it down and
you have respect for your
readership which is what i've always
been told is one of the most important
things as an author and
you're you're a light unto the many of
us who are aspiring to do better and be
better with our writing
i want to thank you for that i want to
ask you a quick question about the
university of the sciences
i i know little about it i always
thought it was like a pharmacy
school can you tell me a little bit
about it and then enter into the
the plug zone oh wow my
public publicity people at the
university were really happy with that
question
we are about to experience our 200th
anniversary or bicentennial
wow we started thank you we started
today over you know 100 to me
we started out as a pharmacy college and
we we split off
from the philadelphia college of
medicine
i think that's what it's called the
doctors the physicians the philadelphia
college of physicians i'm sorry
and um there there were doctors and
originally
they were the only ones who could say
well uh
what are the real medications and then
the pharmacists
said well rather than the doctors just
saying it from memory
let's put this down let's come up with a
pharmacopoeia
and a book about all the medications
that are
that are allowed wow and that led to
the philadelphia college of pharmacy a
bunch of pharmacists who said okay
we can take control of our own
profession now flash forward
more than 100 years later and they're
like well let's add chemists
let's add biologists they kind of relate
to it
and then finally when i was hired um
they hired physicists they didn't have a
physics major yet
but then they started saying let's
become a university
which was very exciting for me as i felt
like
i i felt like i didn't have to switch
jobs because i started out at a pharmacy
college
and then my university switched became a
full-fledged science university
with emphasis on the natural as well as
the health sciences
and then we set up a physics major and
now we finally have a master's program
in physics
so i didn't have to do anything yeah i
should be interested
around you it changed around like the
university developed around me and now
i'm teaching this year all upper-level
physics students or graduate physics
students
and it's very exciting so i really love
teaching here
and they're great students very friendly
students and we're
um we're a rare example of a university
that's hybrid
so you can uh do things online or do
things in person
depending upon the course so i've been
teaching my classes
mostly in person and then i'm giving a
hybrid option or an online option
for students who prefer online so
it's been fun very good and tell us
where we can find you
i i you know i love when people say
where can people find the book as if
it's a great mystery that you have to
derive
you know we can find the book anywhere
and you should listen to it
on audio i particularly recommend that
because it's
it's you get uh the reader you get
paul's words but in someone else's voice
it's it's really well done
uh and get the hardcover as well because
it's actually a beautifully printed and
bound book
i love the way basic does things tj
kelleher i
know him he was your editor i guess for
a little bit maybe for the whole book um
tell us where can people find you on the
internet and in the limited amount which
i
respect of social media that you do so
uh
exceptionally engaging well i'm very
active on
twitter so check out my handle p halpern
my first initial and my last name and i
tweet a lot of history of science things
so that's my
my specialty on twitter um there's a
facebook page
set up by a fellow writer that's a fan
page for my books but i'm not
i'm not active in that but that has
information about me
i don't have an instagram page yet but
but i am
very much on twitter yes you are i i
always enjoy your your photographs your
history
uh historical perspective and i want to
thank you again
paul for coming into the impossible for
venturing into the impossible
and i want to keep in touch with your uh
with your
future work and you're welcome back on
the show anytime it's been such a
pleasure and honor for me to have you on
the show paul
thank you so much brian this is a great
great podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd
[Music]
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco